دخلت موسوعه جينيستاني في سحب اا اتوبيس
في حوالي 50 سيده مرضى السرطان من جمعيه
اللام الحلوه طبعا وانا جالس على الارض
باسحب اا 18 طن مؤخرا سحبت مترو الانفاق
همم في شبرا الخيمه والحمد لله دخلت برده
فيها موسوعه جينيس
لا باكل همم كل يوم طبق بيض فراخ انا ما
يكفنيش فرختين الحمد لله ولا اثنين كيلو
لحمه ولا ثلاثه كيلو لحمه عايز اقول لك
انا في مره بعد ما خلصت تمرين ثلاثه خمسه
كيلو سمك
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي اشرف محروس الشباب مواليد
الاسماعيليه عندي 40 سنه انا رئيس اتحاد
مصارعه المحترفين مؤسس اول مصارعه في مصر
عربي الشرق الاوسط افريقيا وحصل على
موسوعه جينيس اقوى رجل في العالم من خلال
الايام اللي فاتت دي من حوالي ست شهور سبع
شهور والله انا الحاجات اللي انا بعملها
دائما في حياه القوه الخارقه مثلا اللي
انا دائما بسحب تريلات كثيره جدا باسحب من
اول تريلا لحد اربع تريلات طبعا
باسناني كان وزنها همم 16 كلمه متفوق على
الهندي بثلاثه طن والحمد لله سحبتها
الايام اللي فاتت انا مقدم على 15 رقم
قياسي دخلت واي فاي هنا ثاني في سحب همم
اتوبيس في حوالي 50 سيده همم مرضى السرطان
همم جمعيه اللمه الحلوه طبعا وانا جايه
لسه على الارض بس حب همم 18 ثاني مؤخرا
السحبت مترو الانفاق همم في شبرا الخيمه
والحمد لله دخلت برده فيها موسوعه جينيس
مستنيين بقى يرد علي باذن الله في خلال
الايام القادمه جدا همم متحدي القناه دي
اللي هو سحب الت بالزراعين حوالي 30 سم هو
كان محقق 14.5 طن انا ان شاء الله هاحقق
حوالي 16 طن في خلال ايام الجمعه الجايه
ان شاء الله من غير ال 15 بدل قياس اللي
انا ادخله فان شاء الله انوي ارفع اسم مصر
واسم مواطن عربي عاليا وطبعا دي اول مره
واحد مصري عربي او افريقي كمان ياخذ
موسوعه جهازك في العالم وبتحدي العمالقه
طبعا في العالم كله
[موسيقى]
همم طبعا كانت اول مره انا اسحب همم فيها
حاجه ضخمه زي كده كانت موضوع همم لودر
كبير جدا وكان الموضوع بطريقه الصدفه اللي
هو همم قاعد مع اصحابي كان هم همم الكوتش
الاوضه ما كانش مش قادرين عادي انا ممكن
العربيه ملاكي دي بسابعي اسد فعلا زقيته
فتحت الباب العربيه لكن لسه الموضوع كبير
جدا وانا بالنسبه لي الموضوع ده سهل جدا
ده بيقول لودر 66 يعني عادي جدا الكاوتش
بتاع اللودر اعلى مني همم
سحبتها وكان الموضوع صعب جدا جدا ودي كانت
اول حاجه اعملها والله انا بعد كده بعد ما
سحبتها جيت هنا هنا في الطريق ده في جبت
عربيه نقل صغيره كده بتدرب عليها لقيت
الموضوع اكبر من كده اتعرف على واحد صاحبي
كان اسمه احمد همم
قلت له عايز يسحب العربيه دي بقى اسنان
وفيها سحبت العربيه الكلام دي اول تجربه
ضخمه اعملها الناس
استمريت بعد كده على الحاجات الثقيله
والله انا التدريب بتاعي يعني انا دلوقتي
عشان انا عندي الجمعه الجايه باكون باجهز
لها قبلها باسبوع زي النهارده كده همم
هاسحب همم تريله دي طبعا النهارده اللي هو
وزنها تقريبا ما يقارب 27 طن هاسحبها لكن
التدريب بتاعي بيبقى مسابقه الصبح واخر
النهار طبعا بتمرن من صعب جدا شويه هو همم
جيم كقوي بدنيه همم اكل منظم باحاول اعمل
الحاجات دي دائما في اليوم لكن 80 صعب انا
عايز اقول لك ال- ال- الاكل والتمرين
بتكون همم شقه جدا بالنسبه لي باخذ فتره
الاسبوع ده كله التمرين الا اليوم قبل
الحدث بريح فيه عايز اقول لك انا المفروض
يوميا اخذت بالك لكن الظروف المالديه
فباحاول اقلل الموضوع لما تكون الدنيا
حلوه لا باكل همم كل يوم طبق بيض وهمم
فراخ انا ما يكفينيش فرختين الحمد لله ولا
اثنين كيلو لحمه ولا ثلاثه كيلو عايز اقول
لك انا في مره بعد ما خلصت تمرين ثلاثه
خمسه لكن كثير
[موسيقى]
والله الرساله بتاعتي اللي انا بعمله ده
كله الهدف بتاعي ده حلم حياتي طبعا ان انا
اكون اقوى رجل في مصر في الوطن العربي وفي
العالم كله يتسجل باسم تاريخ مصر وتاريخ
الوطن العربي الحاجه التانيه اللي انا
محتاجها الايام دي يعني انا محتاج راعي
كبير جدا راعي يعني بناني عشان اقدر اكمل
المسيره انا لسه عندي 15 رقم قياسي نفسي
اكمل حياتي ان شاء الله اكمل مستقبلي ده
همم
واكسب كوره للارقام اللي كده في مصايبس كا
اقوى رجل في العالم
وانا عندي حاجات كثيره جدا باعملها في
حياتي حاجات كثيره جدا صعب جدا ان احد
يعملها فكان دائما والدتي تمنعني من
الحاجات دي ان انا ابوح بها لاصحابي او
الجيران او اي احد بانصح الناس كلها اولا
يحافظوا على الرياضه صور كبيره او صغير
يحافظوا على الرياضه بامسح الابهات
والامهات ان هم
يخلوا اولادهم يتمرنوا يوميا همم في
الرياضه عامه بيلعبوا اي لعبه رياضيه لكن
همم اللي هو يعمل حاجه زي اللي انا
باعملها نصيحه
يكون عنده قوه من صوره او حاسس ان هو عنده
قوه الجباره كده مختلفه عن الناس ايه يتجه
حاجات اللي انا باعملها لكن ما عندوش قوه
وهو حاب يقلد يا ريت بلاش او يروح لحد
مختصه يكون المدرب او دكتور همم
يحاول يساعده يعني في الحاجات دي فدي لازم
يروح المختص يقدر يساعده دي اهم حاجه يعني
باقولها للجمهور كلها
[موسيقى]